اعلنت الخارجيه البريطانيه وقفه جميع
واردات الغاز الطبيعي المساله من روسيا
اعتبارا من يوم امس وقالت الخارجيه
البريطانيه انها بهذا القرار تقطع عن
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتن احد مصادر
تمويل حربه في اوكرانيا داعيه دول العالم
الى خفض اعتمادها على الغاز الروسيه وتظهر
البيانات الحكوميه ان المملكه المتحده
يستوردت ما قيمته مليونا جنيه استرليني من
النفط من روسيا في الاشهر السبعه التي
اعقبت بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا لكنها لم
تستورد الفحم او الغازه وفي عام 2021 زودت
روسيا المملكه المتحده باربعه في المئه من
احتياجاتها من الغاز وبتسعه في المئه من
احتياجاتها نفطيه 27% من الفحم بقيمه
اجماليه قدرها 4 مليارات ونصف مليار جنيه